well guys slightly different setting for
this video but that's because this is a
very special video this is my 500th
video wow I don't even know what that
even means that's a lot of videos and I
thought to myself I had to do something
special I can't just put up some random
video for a random movie I have to do
something special I'll do something a
lot of people have asked for it I do
something that's really requested
something a lot of people been like Gris
I have to see this please and by far one
of my most requested videos is a blu-ray
collection video in which I show you
guys every film that I own now the
reason I haven't done this yet is simply
because a month from now this video will
be very out of date I will have bought
more blu-rays and now this collection
isn't exactly what I own and so for that
reason I was like what's the point of
doing it I started thinking to myself
though how about I do like one or two of
these a year and you guys can just see
like how much more the collection has
grown and that way you guys can get into
what I own at least see some of my weird
thing because I don't own every great
movie ever let me just say that really
quick there's a lot of movies that I
really enjoy that I don't own I don't
own everything yet I really just started
collecting in the past couple months so
this collection isn't humongous this
isn't some big thing like what my buddy
John the flick pic has I mean he's got
like some thing where he just owns like
every movie I'm also not a completist if
I want to own a certain films in a
series if I don't like the sequel to
that film I'm not going to buy it you
know what I mean I'm not gonna buy x-men
origins just because I like x-men -
that's not how I am my collection is in
alphabetical order and it starts first
with numbers and that very first one is
3:10 to Yuma this is by James Mangold
stars Russell Crowe Christian Bale
really intense movie pretty badass movie
one of my favorite westerns actually and
I really enjoyed this film if you
haven't seen it yet if you haven't
realized by now I'm not going to spend
too much time on these films because
I'll be here forever 10 Things I Hate
About You is one of my favorite 90s
comedies in fact this is one of my
favorite comedies in general it stars
Heath Ledger Julia Stiles and Joseph
gordon-levitt lots of cool people on
this movie now fans of The Criterion
Collection will be disappointed that I
only have one criterion blu-ray but I
picked in my opinion one of the best 12
Angry Men is actually my favorite
black-and-white film I can watch this
film so many times
over and over again and it never gets
old to me now my fiancee Sam actually
suggested that I review 500 days of
summer for my 500th video that's a
really great idea unfortunately I've
already reviewed the film so I didn't
feel that I should do it again but 500
days of summer is actually one of my
favorite indie romances there's an
interesting story with this movie this
is actually the first movie that I ever
drove out of my way to see because it
wasn't playing in any theaters directly
near me it was playing in a theater
about 45 minutes away from me and now
I'm used to that because all of my film
screenings are about 40 minutes from my
house and I Drive to all of them and I'm
used to that now we're back then this is
the first movie that I ever actually
went you know what I really want to see
that I'm going out of my way to see it
and I loved it I loved every second of
it 500 days of summer is all my favorite
romance movies next I have an action
movie that I really loved as a kid and I
still love today
Air Force One with Harrison Ford this is
another one of those movies that I can
watch a couple times a year and still
get really into it now we get to my very
first collection and that is the Alfred
Hitchcock essentials collection this has
rear window vertigo North by Northwest
psycho and the birds which in my opinion
are his best and I love watching each
one of them my favorite one of Alfred
Hitchcock's films is rear window I think
rear window is a master class of
suspense I actually had a privilege of
seeing that in theaters recently they
had a special showing of it in Cleveland
they even showed a Looney Tunes cartoon
before it started and had an organ
player before it started playing the
organ live next I'm going to bunch these
into one thing I have alien and aliens
not alien 3 not alien resurrection not
alien vs. predator and not alien vs.
predator 2 these are the only ones worth
owning in my humble opinion they're both
terrific films I like aliens just a
little bit more James Cameron gave a
really great sci-fi action vibe to it
and it was also very funny and Sigourney
Weaver's performance improved even more
- but alien is still a terrific suspense
film that's really creepy and has this
great sense of Violation to it the way
the aliens infect humans and this next
film I've already done a review for in
my favorite movies segment that's
American Psycho you guys know I love
this movie Christian Bale is fantastic
in it it's hilarious it's very well made
now you guys know I have to have the
Avengers on blu-ray it just you know I
have to it's the ideal suit
hero movie you know I like the Batman
films more myself but for superhero
films for fun comic book films this is
the epitome of what we've had so far it
was terrific
I loved every second of it let me also
just warn you guys you're going to be
like where's your slipcovers Chris oh my
word where's your slipcovers I keep all
my slipcover separate I keep them in a
drawer for two reasons I want to keep
them safe and in good condition just in
case they ever become rare the other
reason is it saves more space on my
shelf if I take the slipcovers off that
way I can have more room because I know
you collectors are like oh my god is he
throw the slipcovers I hate him don't
worry I don't and speaking of the Batman
films I have each one of them on blu-ray
Batman Begins The Dark Knight and the
Dark Knight Rises best comic book films
ever made in my opinion I can't get
enough of these movies I would say every
few months I feel like watching one of
them and I generally do I love every
second of these movies the villains were
so well portrayed Christian Bale was
perfect as Batman Christopher Nolan gave
a great realism to the characters the
script was so well done and so realistic
in the sense where you were able to
actually buy this guy in a bat suit and
it just worked it all worked these are
three of my all-time favorite films
gotta have them a lot of times you guys
ask me Chris what are some of your
favorite comedies I don't know my number
one pick is but I certainly know what
one of them is and that is The Big
Lebowski
this movie is hilarious okay I'm serious
this movie is absurd it's awesome Black
Swan was actually the very first movie I
ever saw out of the United States I saw
this movie in Canada while I was
visiting a friend and it was kind of
funny because there were all these
teenagers in the movie theater because
in Canada this movie is rated 14 a so
there was always 14 year olds like in
the theater and I was like what's going
on this is kind of weird now here's a
movie that every February Walmart has
like this Valentine's Day
rack where you can go and get the
special Valentine's Day movies for you
and your couple to have a nice night and
maybe do little stuff to not elope and
there's always this one movie that's in
there simply because of the title and
every time I see it I'm like that really
should not be in there because any
couple that rents that movie they're
done for Blue Valentine Blue Valentine
is an excellent movie with two fantastic
performances by Ryan Gosling and
Michelle Williams but this is not a
movie that you should be watching with
the
date no I wouldn't feel right as an
action fan and a movie reviewer if I did
not own Braveheart starring Mel Gibson
loved this movie this is actually when
you really think about this movie it's
so famous now because it's Braveheart
but imagine you're in 1995 okay and you
hear that the guy from lethal weapon is
gonna direct a movie this big humongous
movie and then you see it and then he
wins Best Picture for it and then he
wins Best Director for it that's unheard
of really that doesn't really happen
that much hardly at all and Gibson
really deserved it he did a great job in
Braveheart I think it's one of my
favorite action films ever made but it's
not just a really good action film it
has a really good emotional core to it
and that's one of the reasons why I had
resonated with a lot of people I really
loved Braveheart and this next blu-ray
is actually not available in the United
States it was only released in Canada
but since Canada is also region one just
like the United States is it works fine
on us players so to me it doesn't really
matter
brick brick is one of my favorite indie
movies it's actually the first movie I
saw that made me want to do the
overlooked movie review segment and I'm
really glad I did that because it's been
a consistent segment that I've had a lot
of fun doing but this movie is available
in Canada for some reason but not in the
United States and it works just fine on
US players the only difference is that
it has this little French subtitle here
and a rich I shouldn't have lived it dad
so there are a few movies in my
collection that I like and I know that
other people don't like and it's just
kind of a special thing for me maybe I
saw it on the right day maybe I grew up
watching it maybe it just is a nostalgic
film for me and so I own it because of
that I recognize it not everyone likes
this film and there's a few movies in my
collection like that but for me Broken
Arrow is just awesome I love this movie
I don't know what it is it's a really
stupid cheesy action movie but I love it
John Woo directed at John Travolta
Christian Slater it just does something
for me I don't know I just enjoy it now
I have my one and only Blu ray steelbook
and the only reason is because I don't
really care about steal books you know
there's always an edition of that same
film for much cheaper I don't care if I
get a little knick or a dent in it I
always on my does it dent so I never
really cared that much about steal books
but this was a really good price so I
got Chinatown on steelbook with Jack
Nicholson and Faye Dunaway this is a
classic movie it's got a lot of classic
moments in it it's so fan
hastily acted it's back in Jack
Nicholson's prime when he was really
getting well-known for his acting
performances now I'm a big Harrison Ford
fan and you guys may know that but I
really liked clear and present danger
this is one of his Jack Ryan films
the other one was Patriot Games that
came before this I don't have Patriot
games yet I do want to get it but I
haven't got a chance to get it yet I
also don't have Hunt for Red October yet
but I do want to get that one for sure I
don't really care for the sum of all
fear so much though there won't have
been a flick hopefully Jack Ryan with
Chris Pine later this year is good but
clearing present danger is a pretty fun
film it's it's not like an action movie
you know it's it's more of a thriller
really where you have like really big
scenes there's this great scene with
Harrison Ford and Henry's journey I
think you say his name the guy from
Mission Impossible and yeah overall
clear and present dangers a lot of fun
if you hadn't checked it out yet William
Dafoe was in it as well pretty good
movie my next film is a very underrated
film in my opinion is actually one of my
favorite movies stars Tom Cruise and
Jamie Foxx and that is collateral by
Michael Mann this is a hugely realistic
vision of City nightlife I adore the way
this film is directed there are so many
things about this movie that are not
Hollywood eyes the sound effects the
location the lighting the use of HD
cameras so much of this movie feels so
in the moment you just get this
incredible feel from it the kind of
reminds me of Cowboy Bebop at times with
the music and the look of the film the
performances are great it might be my
favorite Tom Cruise performance actually
I'm not positive on that but he is
excellent in this movie as is Jamie Foxx
this is the movie that really helped
Jamie Foxx he had this and Rey in the
same year and this was a movie that year
that proved that he can do more than
just imitate Ray Charles and that was a
lot for him this is a great movie if you
haven't seen collateral yet please check
it out next is the Cowboy Bebop movie
this is my favorite anime I adore Cowboy
Bebop and I love the movie as well if
you haven't seen the show dude check it
out it's a great anime show and I
strongly suggest the movie as well and
once again we have one of those movies
that's just special for me you know a
lot of people like this relief it grew
up with it in the 80s if you watch it as
a kid to me it's a special movie it's
just incredible if you have not seen
commando with Arnold Schwarzenegger
you haven't lived all the way yet
come on Bennet its body in the vein of
the last movie that I just mentioned we
have one of the cheesiest action movies
ever made and I love every single second
of it and that is Conair how can you not
like look at that look at that Nicholas
Cage with long hair it's impossible you
have to like it it's okay if you don't
but I mean come on Nicolas Cage holding
a bunny with Trisha Yearwood singing how
do I well he looks at his little girl
you can't beat it man it's
Conair it's so horrible oh my god I love
it though I don't know it's a guilty
pleasure for me next we have a Crazy
Stupid Love a film that has three great
central performances that of Steve
Carell Julianne Moore and Ryan Gosling
especially Ryan Gosling in this movie I
mean he really stole the show in this
movie in my opinion not just because I'm
a fan of his
I thought his character was so well done
and entertaining and miss stone is
pretty good in the movie also I don't
want to forget her now besides my cowboy
bebop movie I haven't really mentioned
any foreign films yet and we have
Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon this is
one of my favorite foreign films this is
one of the few foreign films that
actually broke through the United States
mold and became a really humongous
box-office success in the States next we
have one of my favorite Martin Scorsese
films in fact it might actually be my
favorite the departed terrific film
DiCaprio Nicholson Damon David sorry
Wahlberg was also great in this movie
actually oscar-nominated to Alec Baldwin
Martin Sheen this movie had an
incredible cast and I can tell you why
the script is airtight and it's
extremely riveting you guys knew this
was coming drive drive is one of my
favorite films
it was a humongously impactful movie
when I first saw it it's a beautiful
looking blu-ray the picture quality is
terrific doesn't help the cinematography
is already fantastic but this is a kind
of movie that a lot of people reported
seeing a second time and suddenly really
liking the first time I saw they didn't
really get what was going on because I
thought it was going to be more of a
transport type thing definitely not that
type of movie a lot of people loved it
the second time and I'm actually hearing
a lot of the same things happening with
only God forgives myself included I
ended up liking it more as I watched it
a few more times the next we have a film
that some people didn't really like that
some people thought could have been
better
myself included I actually do think this
when we could have been better but
there's something about it that keeps
drawing me back to it and I think it's
because Mel Gibson is in this movie edge
of darkness and he gave such a great
performance as this really broken father
who was going slightly insane because of
this thing that happened to him with his
daughter and it all worked really well
for me I thought it was a really well
directed movie by Martin Campbell it
also stars Ray Winstone and although the
film could have been a little bit better
than I thought it was it was a little
too boring at times there were aspects
of this movie that I thought were truly
brilliant and for that reason I do own
the film because I enjoy watching it
from time to time okay now this is a
childhood classic for me i watch this
film a few times a year I cry it just
affects me John Williams music it just I
don't even know what's going on et is a
film that I don't really have to say
much about if you haven't seen it yet
what the what just go watch it man it's
et it's fantastic and you have to see it
at least once in your life next we have
another film that some people regard as
a masterpiece a lot of people think it
wasn't that great I think it's terrific
Eyes Wide Shut Stanley Kubrick's last
film Tom Cruise Nicole Kidman this is
the type of movie that is such a mind
cluster bomb of death when you're
watching yours like what is this it's
very much kind of like only God forgives
the first time I saw it and then I
started thinking about it and thinking
about it and thinking about it I
couldn't get it to escape my brain I
really like eyes wide shut
here's another film that I grew up with
that is actually one of my favorite
movies also this is a film that really
inspired me as a teenager I got really
into the idea of baseball and the sort
of mystic quality that it has because of
Field of Dreams I think this is a
terrific movie with a great score by
James Horner a really good performance
by Kevin Costner and James Earl Jones
and it's horrific ending if you guys
have not seen Field of Dreams yet
because it is kind of a 80s movie and a
lot of people haven't got a chance to
see it yet I really think that Field of
Dreams is a kind of movie that has
slipped under the radar a little bit for
a lot of movie fans and this next movie
is one of the best films that came out
in the 90s it stars Brad Pitt and Edward
Norton and that is Fight Club directed
by David Fincher this is the kind of
movie the first time I saw it I was like
wow that is a really deep dark intense
movie but I could not get the style of
it out of my mind and this story was so
different and interesting but this is
definitely one of the types of movies
that has a little bit more style over
substance
and it really works because david
fincher used his style to almost boost
the substance and I really like the way
this film was made and the acting the
performances it's definitely one of the
most entertaining films ever made if you
can get over some of the more graphic
moments and we are back in Harrison Ford
Ville with the fugitive definitely one
of the best films that came out in the
90s this is the prime example of a
straight forward action thriller being
as good as it could possibly be Harrison
Ford was so sympathetic in this role you
really felt for him he was just the
perfect casting for this movie because
you knew he didn't do it and you really
wanted him to be okay but you also
really loved Tommy Lee Jones his
character who was after him as well
and that the way those characters went
back and forth really boosted this movie
and I really enjoyed the fugitive it's
definitely movie I grew up with and it
could watch over and over again
countless times and I have watched it
over and over again that kind of feel
like watching it now
the fugitive The Girl with the Dragon
Tattoo another David Fincher film Daniel
Craig Rooney Mara terrific performances
another film that just looks so great
and there's actually quite a bit of CGI
that was used to accomplish some of the
shots which is Lily interesting because
they read Fincher hit it very well and I
was really impressed with that
I'm so sad this but we didn't do
incredible at the American box office
because now David Fincher apparently
isn't doing a sequel we're never gonna
get to see the rest of it ah I'll go
watch the originals next we have a film
that really boosted Matt Damon's and Ben
Affleck's career Good Will Hunting and
also Robin Williams because he won his
first Oscar for this movie this is such
an emotional movie this is one of those
movies that has such a rawness to it now
as I said earlier I do have a couple
films that a lot of people consider bad
and I completely understand that because
this movie is kind of stupid but this is
another guilty pleasure for me for some
reason I saw this movie at just the
right day okay and I don't know what it
was I just really had fun basically
laughing at the silliness of this movie
and I had fun and I enjoy myself gone
with Amanda Seyfried it's a stupid movie
it's silly but something about it I like
it and I only it was only five bucks so
I'd picked it up and you know what I
don't mind this movie next we have Ben
Affleck's directorial debut Gone Baby
Gone this movie really impressed a lot
of people myself included terrific
performances all-around fantastic script
really really dramatic story
I loved comedy
be gone a lot now I have two more films
I'm going to group into one that's
Hellboy one and two these are two really
underrated superhero movies that a lot
of people actually don't know that much
about I didn't see him in theaters when
they came out and I'm really
disappointed that I didn't because these
are a lot of fun Ron Perlman is terrific
as Hellboy
Guillermo del Toro did a great job with
the visuals and there's some of my
favorite superhero movies actually now
especially the second one I love the
second one I thought it was such an
improvement over the first one and I
even enjoyed that one too now we have
one of Steven Spielberg's most maligned
films that I don't get it personally cuz
uh hook you know it's awesome I called
the year 2011 the year of Gosling
because Crazy Stupid Love drive and Ides
of March fantastic film directed by
George Clooney starring George Clooney
and Ryan Gosling I really enjoyed this
movie and the reason I think this movie
is so great is because I am so not into
politics at all yet I found this movie
completely riveting from beginning to
end I'll never forget the first time I
saw inception inception was like just oh
because the Dark Knight blew me away
and when inception came out I was like
yes this guy this guy is truly
incredible this director Christopher
Nolan this is one of my favorite science
fiction films it's one of my favorite
action films and that's one of the
things I love about it it's such a great
combination of action and science
fiction and it's so original even though
it borrows from other films I thought
that it did a great job from it I know
that a lot of people said it borrowed
off with their anime film paprika which
I can understand but in all honesty
every film borrows off of other films it
just it's going to happen
you're either copying or you're
borrowing or you're paying homage or
it's similar to another idea
it happens an inception in my opinion is
a fantastic movie all on its own
Independence Day I just did a review for
this on July 4th my buddy John for the
flick pic channel you guys know I enjoy
this movie I think it's a lot of fun and
I grew up watching Independence Day and
it has some really fun performances and
some fun moments even though some of the
CGI is a little bit dated I have a lot
of fun with the dependents day and I
just said fun like seven times because
that's what this movie is if you guys
know anything about me you know that I
love Indiana Jones the Indiana Jones
collection on blu-ray is a must-own for
me I absolutely adore this collection
it's one of my favorite things that I
have
I think it's a beautiful beautiful
collection it has really really great
custom artwork for each film Raiders
temple Last Crusade and this is actually
a really well directed movie to me was
just a script and some of the characters
that were the problem very disappointing
but I still enjoyed aspects of it Last
Crusade is probably my favorite Temple
of Doom and Raiders I almost like
equally I think Temple of Doom is one of
the most underrated movies ever made but
if you don't have this and you're a
movie fan I'm like why you have to next
on the list we have one of my favorite
Tarantino films possibly actually my
favorite Tarantino film and that isn't
glorious bastards not a popular opinion
a lot of people are like what Pulp
Fiction Reservoir Dogs you know great
movies on their own right but I for some
reason really enjoying glorious bastards
now as I said there are still some films
that I don't own yet that I want to own
like pulp fiction don't have that yet
like the Kill Bill films don't have them
yet next we have one of Christopher
Nolan's much earlier films insomnia I
think this is also a very underrated
movie great performance by Al Pacino and
Robin Williams I think this is a
terrific crime thriller a lot of people
don't judge this movie correctly in my
opinion they think Walter Christopher
Nolan movie has to be epic
judge this film on the genre that it
encompasses crime thriller it's
top-notch next we have an Iron Man I do
not own Iron Man 2 because I'm not like
Iron Man 2 and as I said I'm not a
completist if I don't like a certain
film in a series
I'm not going to own it unless it comes
in a giant collection or something and
you have to own it then that's just
gonna happen Iron Man is one of my
favorite superhero films this is also a
big surprise because Robert Downey jr.
at that time wasn't at the level he was
now this is the movie that made him
extremely famous again because he had a
lot of problems in life and this one we
surprised a lot of people is directed by
an actor it starred Robert Downey jr.
and it was incredible next time we list
you have a film that came out late last
year that I personally really enjoyed
and that was Jack Reacher with Tom
Cruise I thought this film really
captured the character really well and
for once I can actually say that having
read one of the books I read the book
killing floor and I really thought that
the character here was very close to the
character I saw in the movie despite the
fact that here he's like 6 4 and Tom
Cruise is 5 7
this film is an absolute classic jaws
and it looks terrific on blu-ray it was
such a cool experience seeing this on
blu-ray I've seen the movie a billion
times it was almost like watching it
again because I could see the crispness
of the colors the clarity of the image
and everything just was so improved from
the original negative of the film now
once again we come to a film that I like
because I grew up with it some people
may not like it but that's fine I don't
care because I own Jumanji seriously
though this movies kind of awesome I
don't know what it is I really liked you
mangy I grew up with it that's probably
why I had the clam shell giant VHS case
of it as a kid I still enjoy this film
quite a bit it's directed by Joe
Johnston who later went on to direct
Captain America Robin Williams is a lot
of fun this movie I always wanted the
board game when I was a kid and I was
always hoping it was gonna come alive
and things are gonna happen it was
obviously a movie that was made then the
the board game was sold and it made a
lot of merchandising profits and
everything but I enjoyed you mangy it
was a fun movie for me as a kid and I
still like it as an adult now once again
I am NOT a completist
I have Jurassic Park and the lost world
and not the third one because I don't
like it a lot of people really don't
like the lost world that much I think
it's pretty underrated I honestly think
this is a very strong movie until the
whole city section at the end a lot of
people thought that that's where it
breached and it was like this feels like
a different movie and I completely agree
with that but up until then I think the
Lost Worlds a terrific film Jurassic
Park is a classic here's another film
that I think is just magnificent that is
so underrated and that is the Last
Samurai I think this is one of Cruz's
best movies and one of his best
performances this movie really captured
the beauty of another culture of another
land and a lot of people were like oh
Tom Cruise the Last Samurai he is not
the Last Samurai in the movie this
always annoys me I see comments like Oh
Tom Cruise always has to be the big guy
because he's the last samurai samurai is
plural okay it's about the last living
samurai people it's not Tom Cruise being
the Last Samurai sorry for that little
rant it just always bugs me when I see
that please check this movie out if you
haven't seen it I really think it'd be
worth your time next we have the first
film that I saw the Toronto
International Film Festival Joseph
gordon-levitt and director Rian Johnson
came out and introduced looper it was
such an incredible
we'll be to see there at the true
premier with all the stars everyone is
dressed up but it wasn't just the cool
event a movie was so different in
original and that's one of the things
that's so great about looper
it's a terrific screenplay it looks
great it was so well acted but it was so
original and different as well and
that's what I loved about it was a movie
that actually made time-travel work
which is really hard to do next we have
the Lord of the Rings trilogy I know
you're about to say why don't you have
the extended editions I prefer the
theatrical editions I honestly do and a
lot of fans are about to shoot me in the
face but the thing is I don't like an
extra hour of scenes that although are
well made to be honest we're cut out of
the movie for a reason the extended
editions are really fun for hardcore
fans of the novels and of the film's to
really delve into those things but I
like to watch the films the theatrical
versions because those are the films
that in my opinion are paced the best so
these are three terrific terrific movies
that honestly when I watch them now the
special effects don't even seem dated
and I'm so amazed at how great of a job
Peter Jackson did at capturing those
novels next we have another one of my
all-time favorite films that is the
matrix this movie really inspired me as
a kid I remember my friends and I going
out and making matrix fan films and
trying to imitate the moves and all the
slow motion and everything and we just
had such a great time with the matrix
it's a movie that was constantly
imitated because it really opened the
eyes of filmmakers in regards to special
effects and a lot of people were trying
to then all of a sudden imitate though
the world creation of the matrix had no
one has ever done it as successfully
awesome movie next we have another one
of Christopher Nolan's early films
memento this is a type of movie that
demands repeat viewings you can't watch
this movie once and just latch onto it
it's just the kind of movie that you
want to watch again and again next we
have one of my favorite Clint Eastwood
movies and one of my favorite films that
he did direct Million Dollar Baby three
terrific performances that of him Hilary
Swank and Morgan Freeman I'll never
forget the first time I saw this movie
in theaters I was able to convince to my
friends to go to it they were like why
are we seeing this movie called Million
Dollar Baby and they left the film so
impacted by it I'll never forget that
and I felt the exact same way next we
have another Spielberg film and one of
my favorite Spielberg films and one of
his more underrated films Minority
Report this movie is awesome and now we
have Mission Impossible one two three
and Ghost Protocol this
is one of my favorite film franchises I
liked pretty much all of them too is
definitely the weakest one but they all
have really great moments to them they
already saw that I own The Big Lebowski
my other Coen Brothers movie is No
Country for Old Men
another really well directed movie with
terrific performances this is a movie
that a lot of people are a little
offense about simply because of the way
it concludes you know what I really
liked it I really think that it's
different and I like the fact that they
were able to create a sense of
detachment from a few of the characters
where you were with them and you really
wanted them to succeed but you really
felt as if you were more on the ride
that the filmmakers were taking you so
when certain things happen it didn't
bother me Oh as it did other people and
now I have the oceans trilogy ocean's 11
by far is the best one and I think this
is actually a mazing movie one of the
best directed movies I've ever seen
Steven Soderbergh did a great job of
combining arthouse elements with
mainstream elements to make such a great
movie and although 12 and 13 weren't as
good I everytime watch the first one I
do feel like watching the others which
is why I own them and I do enjoy 12 and
13 too
but the first one is so good now as you
guys know I am a fan of scary movies I
do like to be creeped out by film the
others definitely did that job very well
Nicole Kidman was great in this movie
very nice to look at but it was also a
really atmospheric movie that was very
well directed and I had a lot of fun
with the others alright guys were on my
last row here we're starting off with
the Patriot the Patriots another Mel
Gibson movie that came out and after
Braveheart it was another period piece
Mel Gibson war movie for some reason
it's that one movie role and I'm Rick
maid that was way beyond the level of
his other films a lot of people were
complaining about the fact that doesn't
follow history to a tee I'm fine with
that this is a really great film also
starring Heath Ledger in a very good
performance I really enjoy the Patriot
now speaking of Mel Gibson payback the
straight-up director's cut so much
better than the original in my opinion
it's honestly a completely different
movie it has a whole nother IMDB page
simply for this film and the only way
that a director's cut can have another
IMDB page is if it honestly is a
different movie in the eyes of IMDB like
if enough has been changed to warrant a
second page for it they'll make one
completely different movie
different ending different beginning
different color scheme even this movie
is so much better than the original
because the original there was all this
feuding with the director and they they
even fired him and another person took
over this movie is his original vision
as best as it could and realized Gibson
is great in this version if he's checked
out the first one thought it was kind of
ant check out the director's cut much
better and I honestly never buy into the
director cut hypes of films to me it's
just they added some deleted scenes most
of the time and it's never that much
better this one truly is better now we
have what is so far my favorite film of
2013 I saw this film at the Toronto Film
Festival last year and I had the
opportunity to actually buy this film
today because an awesome store by my
house sometimes will put out a blu-ray a
few days before it's supposed to come
out the place beyond the pines comes out
on Tuesday I got it a little bit early
which is pretty awesome I love that
store I love this film I can't wait to
watch it a second time because I
actually have not seen it since
September still I love seeing this in
theaters Gosling was there Bradley
Cooper was there Eva Mendes was there
the whole cast of director everyone
there was a great Q&A with them
afterwards it was so much fun to be
there for that experience and this is a
type movie that surprised me so much on
so many levels I'm so glad that I
finally have it on blu-ray and I can
watch it again now this next film is
definitely one of those movies where you
just I don't know what else to say but
to show it to you Point Break its Point
Break and that's all I'm gonna say
Patrick Swayze Keanu Reeves surfers FBI
agents bank robberies what else do you
want now if you guys have been following
my newer segments on my favorite films
you would have seen my review of
predator one of my favorite movies as I
just said I just I love this movie it's
directed by John McTiernan who did die
hard and there's aspects of this film
that is just so well done and Arnold is
actually really great in this movie and
it has a really good sense of sci-fi and
action combined really love predator
here's another one of Nolan's movies
that's pretty underrated and that is the
prestige this film stars Hugh Jackman
Christian Bale and Scarlett Johansson
Michael Caine and David Bowie believe it
or not and you know what that guy can
actually act really well hey labyrinth
labyrinth right this next film for me is
a childhood classic I watched this film
like once a week
going up whenever I was sick from school
had to stay home this was the movie that
I wanted to watch the Sandlot Panza this
movie can quote it from beginning to end
myself included such a great movie it's
such a childhood film but it also is
really heartfelt and just just awesome
we have yet another Steven Spielberg
film here Saving Private Ryan one of his
best films truly a horrific film to
watch really honestly the first time I
saw this movie there were moments I
couldn't look at the screen and that's
saying something for me I've seen a lot
of movies and it's such an intense movie
it really truly is the definition of
intense Saving Private Ryan Zamu V you
have to see at least once in your life
because honestly there are times and I'm
like I don't know if I can watch that
movie right now but every once in a
while I definitely feel like checking
this film out because it's such a great
tribute to men of war and it's really
truly a beautiful movie now here's a
movie that I think is really truly
underrated with a pretty cool ending I
really like the book as well which I own
by Stephen King and that is secret
window with Johnny Depp I really wish
he'd do more performances like this that
have a cool different vibe to it but at
the same time it's a real grounded
person I'm also very excited that he is
teaming up again with David Koepp for
his new movie Mordecai coming out soon I
really enjoy seeker one no I think it's
a creepy movie I think it's an
entertaining and funny movie but I think
it has a terrific ending as well and a
lot of people were bothered by that
ending and I can understand why but I
really enjoyed seeker Wicca quite a bit
here's another one of my all-time
favorite movies and that is 7 this is
actually my favorite David Fincher film
as I just talked about with secret
window speaking of endings 7 has one of
the best endings hands down ever put to
film if you have not seen 7 prepare
yourself because this thing is a machine
this movie is incredible a lot of people
have asked me what my favorite Stanley
Kubrick movie is the answer is the
shining with Jack Nicholson I like 2001
a Space Odyssey I liked Eyes Wide Shut I
liked a lot of his films but the shining
is the one that I keep wanting to watch
whenever I feel like watching a Stanley
Kubrick movie Jack Nicholson's
performance is so great in the movie in
my opinion one of Martin Scorsese's most
underrated films is shutter island' with
Leonardo DiCaprio Mark Ruffalo and Ben
Kingsley and it has a great off-kilter
sense to it where you feel a little bit
nuts as you watch it and I love that
about this movie also the musical
choices they used in
film because it doesn't have a score if
the score was taken from other pieces of
orchestrations and great choices because
they really work well now we have the
film that started it all for me as a
filmmaker as a film critic this is a
movie that I saw that made me want to
delve into films more that made me want
to be a film critic signs I saw in 2002
and this will be just impressed me quite
a bit to this day it's my favorite M
night Shyamalan film I love this movie
there are so many different defenses I
can lay up for why this movie's awesome
I'm thinking about doing a science
analyze review one day to be able to do
that for this day every time I watch
this movie it just gets better and
better it's such an incredible movie I
loved every second of science the
Silence of the Lambs is definitely a
creepy movie featuring one of the best
performances ever by Anthony Hopkins
Jodie Foster not to be overlooked very
good in this movie and I'm telling you
she does some for me man even today she
still does something for me I don't know
what it is about that woman but she does
something for me too bad she plays for
the other team one of my favorite movies
that came out in 2012 was silver linings
playbook I thought this was such a great
movie with Bradley Cooper and Jennifer
Lawrence it has such a great emotional
vibe to it and it was also kind of cool
to see Chris Tucker back in a movie that
wasn't rush hour which is awesome it's a
kind of movie that I felt so into as I
watched it like the characters didn't
feel like fake people I really felt like
I was watching real people interact The
Sixth Sense you can't really not have it
if you're a fan of Shyamalan it's kind
of like his most famous movie it's the
big twist and it started everything The
Sixth Sense is a great movie it's one of
the first ones that Bruce Willis it was
in where people were like wow that guy
could actually really act and Haley Joel
Osment I see dead people one of the best
child performances ever given in a movie
next we have Skyfall which is one of my
favorite Bond films my second favorite
actually second only took a Sina Royale
speaking of bond I have not yet shown
you my bond 50th anniversary collection
this features every single Bond film on
blu-ray and with Skyfall I officially
have them all on blu-ray this is kind of
the crown jewel of my entire thing and
with them together I'm very happy to say
bond love it next we have JJ Abrams Star
Trek this movie really changed a lot of
people's opinion of Star Trek goes up
into this movie it was very much kind of
like a cult thing yeah the like Star
Trek it didn't this movie really helped
it be a little bit more mainstream and
was also a great movie to boot
same time no yes I do have the original
Star Wars films on blu-ray despite some
of the changes I've basically accepted
the fact that the changes are going to
happen whatever
I love these movies there are three of
my all-time favorite films Empire
Strikes Back is my favorite then Star
Wars The Return of the Jedi yes the film
is still called Star Wars to me not a
new hope it was called Star Wars when it
came out and to me it still is I love
these movies they're so great I've loved
me ever since I was a kid and I watched
the original uncut ones on VHS tape for
the first time and I still love him to
this day super 8 was a really fun movie
for me because it felt like The Goonies
and Close Encounters of the Third Kind
all wrapped up into one
and JJ Abrams did such a great job with
this movie I really like the children's
central performances Spielberg as a
producer and even though it felt like
Goonies and Close Encounters all in one
the biggest inspiration was definitely
ET and you can really see it in this
movie and although there are times where
you feel like it might be copying off it
a little bit I still had quite a bit of
fun with it and since Spielberg produced
it it's like okay he's paying homage to
Spielberg for sure next we have taken
and only taken never and never will I
have taken two taken is a great action
movie that really started the whole Liam
Neeson I'm going to break your neck with
my pinky and he did such a good job in
this movie he was already famous for
films like Schindler's List and episode
1 Star Wars Phantom Menace but this film
really helped him get more of an action
vibe to it even though he was older and
it really helped kickstart that whole
old guys can still kick ass kind of
thing really enjoyed taking quite a bit
next we have Terminator 1 & 2 in my
opinion the only ones worth owning two
is one of the best action films ever
made and one is one of the better action
films that came out in the 80s such a
great revelation and swartz nigger if it
wasn't for this movie we probably
wouldn't see him the same way that we do
today for sure but Terminator 2 was
really the one that was like wow what a
terrific action movie next we have
another film that is most definitely a
guilty pleasure for me that I grew up
with that is just yeah don't don't laugh
at me but you can if you want I own Tomb
Raider uh um
I own tomb raider on blue ray what can I
say the second one's coming out on
blu-ray on October 8th how do I know
that because I like it this is a really
stupid movie but I really enjoyed for
some reason it's just a guilty pleasure
for me and Angelina Jolie is hot and
it's directed by Simon West Conair
Expendables 2 that is like this movie
after Gone Baby Gone Ben Affleck proved
that he could still direct a great movie
with the town really terrific movie with
some great action sequences excellent
performances but a really good dramatic
story as well and after this he made
Argo that guy is a serious directing
talent now today a lot of people have
actually changed their mind about M
night Shyamalan in regards to a certain
film unbreakable for a lot of people is
actually their favorite M night
Shyamalan film and I can see why because
I like it more than $0.06 personally I
think this is such a cool superhero film
because it actually is kind of a
superhero film it's a comic book film in
a way but it's original it's its own
tale and I really love the original way
that Shyamalan structured this movie
this is in my opinion definitely one of
his best great performance by Willis
great performance by Samuel Jackson
Robin Wright Penn is also very good in
the movie the score by James Newton
Howard is also fantastic here's another
pretty underrated movie Valkyrie with
Tom Cruise by Bryan Singer this movie to
me was a pretty suspenseful tale with a
really heart-wrenching emotional finale
that I thought really worked there were
aspects of it that could have been
better I'll admit that for sure there
were certain parts of the pacing that
could have been a little bit stronger
some of the characterizations could have
been better but for the most part I
really enjoyed Valkyrie it wasn't quite
as suspenseful or white-knuckled as it
could have been but I'm not entirely
sure that's what Bryan Singer was going
for nevertheless I really enjoyed this
movie and thought it was a really
well-done film war the worlds has some
great moments in it has some really
truly great moments in it and then it
has Justin Chatwin thanks Justin Chatwin
we're gonna get back at them we're gonna
get back at them get back at them
seriously he kind of ruined every scene
he was in in this movie honestly he's my
least favorite actor if you guys didn't
know but I do really enjoy War of the
Worlds I think it's a fun movie with
some great moments
and then the ending is very cheesy and
basically everything involving Justin
Chatwin if you just took up that
character this movie would be great in
my opinion but I still have fun watching
it in the final movie in the Mel Gibson
trilogy of war we who are soldiers I
enjoyed this movie quite a bit now I'm
going to group three movies into one and
the only three in the series worth
owning x-men one two and first class not
three and not origins and when the
Wolverine comes out I will be buying
that as well I think that x-men is a
film that if we didn't have this film we
wouldn't have superheroes the way we
have today it came out in 2000 before
that we had Batman we had Superman but
this was the movie that really showed
people like hey you know what we can
take other more lesser-known comic-book
heroes and make it awesome x2 was even
better it did everything better and
x-men first class was a humungous
surprise for me that I really didn't
think was going to be good at all
because of the terrible posters the
terrible production photos and the
trailer that wasn't really that great my
opinion but it was a lot of fun and I
can't wait to see Days of Future past my
last film on this list is a blu-ray that
was really rare and out of print for a
long time it costs like a hundred and
fifty dollars on Amazon but they finally
put it back in print zodiac which is one
of Fincher's most underrated movies
haven't seen zodiac it's a long ride but
it is most definitely worth it because
it's such an intense experience and it's
the kind of film that makes you really
feel like you're in the moment you're in
the scenes you're with the characters
and it all feels very realistic well
guys that is my blu-ray collection right
now there are certain blu-rays that I
don't own yet that I really want to get
there'll be more than I buy in the
future I assure you but for now thanks
very much for watching this video it's a
longer video I know thanks very much
also to all my subscribers my 500th
video is so great thank you so much as
always guys if you liked this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes